[Music]
okay
welcome
[Music]
to the show
there we go nice
is that too high
okay so here we are in Dania Beach
yeah hell yeah we're stuck here
we need to get out somebody please help
us yeah this place is gross and uh
library and white
you mean like the skin yeah
and personalities
well we just flew a drone over by the
park with a bunch of children in it yeah
that was I was really nervous right now
it was kind of uncomfortable yeah
there's so many things I could have
dropping in that couple of minutes
yeah
yeah I could have sliced a child he
could have sliced a child a parent could
have gone crazy
[Music]
well hopefully it was didn't look weird
or anything yeah at one point the kid
started screaming the Drone took a
picture and I was like all right this
isn't good
it wasn't a picture it was just the
spotlight yeah but they're just dumb ass
kids they don't know anything about
anything
I don't know about drone life
yeah they were going a little crazy yeah
yeah at one point they started praying
for the Drone to come back
who raised these kids yeah I don't know
what that was I don't know if they were
actually praying you think they were
actually praying I don't know but it was
scary
I've never seen children do anything
like that
yeah it was a real
island of the Crystal Skull Indiana
Jones yeah
and then like 20 feet away from that
were a bunch of special kids who did not
care about the drone at all they were
afraid of it yeah yeah
they're much more interested in like
the leaves and stuff on the trees
the what
they're much more interested on like uh
anything else going on
yeah
they were
they were trying not to be interested I
think yeah
they're trying some cool yeah you know
how those retards are
all of a sudden it stopped
uh
whatever
what are we gonna do
oh man monster is it a zoom
ouch
so what do you think you think uh we
should maybe try to figure out what's
wrong with this
thing yeah I think that's a good idea
foreign
what is going on
is it working he said it's working
uh what do you think we should do
um I don't know I don't know how much
is it
oh is it just Frozen maybe it's just on
that
I don't know what happened maybe the
power source going out kind of [__] it
up this stuff happened in there that's
where I came
so
yeah
this is uh looks like
why why is this not working now
uh
and we're back welcome back we're here
we're Queer as soon as we mentioned
special kids everything went crazy I
think they control
technology
that's
very true uh special kids of special
powers yeah I think they do there's
something on there so this is Captain
right here everybody the captain of
this [__] yeah the Dania Beach ship
so how is it that you uh met that guy
from New Smyrna Beach
um I did
his he used to not have that club that's
like a new club and he opened it like
recently but before that he ran a room
in like a like a hotel reception Lobby
basically
and it was fun I did that once how did
he come to book you uh I think he booked
one of my friends and my friends was
like oh can I bring another guy and then
he liked you yeah he's like bro you're
the [__] best bro that [__] [__]
was [__] hilarious and I was like all
right yeah yeah it's fun it was like
really intense he's very intense but
he's a nice guy I guess yeah I think he
might be gay oh you think so yeah really
I just want that to be known to people
I just think that's the kind of guy that
would uh handle gay accusations in a
funny way like what how would he handle
it like it'd be like yeah so what I'm
gay yeah and then he got him drunk one
day and he's like I'm not gay
that's good yeah yeah he does have a lot
of rings which like I think once you get
past six rings on your finger it's like
okay what's happening
what's going on something's not right
yeah he's uh like a pirate
yeah he's like the pirate of New Smyrna
Beach he's a modern day right yeah all
the Pirates had to come to land isn't it
sad that there are no Pirates anymore
yeah I think there is
in like Somalia yeah like Somalia but
you'd think like with technology anyone
could have a boat and then you could
just like be out on the sea and just
catch things for a living and yeah I
just live off the uh
that's true
we did go backwards we barely even used
the sea anymore
like we barely throw car batteries in
there
you know it's the best way to move stuff
is the sea yeah that makes you most it
was so much stuff on a boat and then
have Pirates come and steal it yeah
which I feel like Somalian pirates have
been around forever but they haven't
gotten better at what they do
no they all they can't ever steal stuff
from the boats well I feel like they're
only limited by their resources like
they can only buy boats but if they were
Rich if they could make like a good
living if they could get a foothold yeah
nothing is like the Monopoly of power
and we have so much like more technology
that it's impossible for them to get
started yeah but if they pull off one
good thing they could probably just
blossom
yeah into these pirate Merchant people
yeah I think that's that should be a
goal of somebody we shouldn't all just
be cubicle workers
yeah at least they're free
yeah they're doing stuff on their own
terms
it's just everyone's life has become so
homogenized we all have the same lives
it's like boring yeah
yeah we had a [__] on them we're like oh
they they stealing stuff but they're
living their own life
yeah they're having fun it's got to be
fun doing that yeah it's if if it's
nothing else it'd be fun
yeah you get to hang out with your Bros
all day in a boat
then go and try to steal some oil
like yes it makes sense it's like oh if
we get more of this then I get more
money yeah it's over there I need to go
get it it's not gonna go get itself
but then here in the modern world it's
like oh I got to be the receptionist at
this company so that more people can
come in and have it have their
experience be a little easier and that
you can tell them where the water is and
bring them coffee
and that helps the company which helps
the shareholders get more money and
you're just trying to get as much money
as possible and
that's more like
yeah
like theoretical yeah it's more straight
to the point you know when you're a
pirate
there's like a lot more going on it's
like
can we pull this off yeah
it sucks that people still have to get
vaccinated across the Canadian USA
border I was hoping to see Hans in
Vancouver
foreign
I think it's working yeah
there's a lot of Canadian people here
did you notice that in Dania Florida no
just this like little area oh like I see
a ton of like Canadian license plates
and then I saw Air Canada plane take off
and I was like is this where they're
coming
yeah that's like it makes sense though I
guess yeah
foreign
I mean if I was in Canada I'd be like
let's get out of here
it kind of seems so weird there's like
four
major areas and this huge
country
Canada yeah
yeah it's Vancouver Toronto Quebec
Montreal
yeah and there's
whatever
most people in Canada live below the USA
Canada Border that's so true yeah
because there's like Michigan's up here
and then like Canada's down here yeah so
their their posers basically yeah
they're basically just Michigan
yeah the best part of Canada is just
Michigan
that's where I can imagine if our best
part was Michigan we don't have any New
York yeah
that would just suck I would kill myself
yeah that'd be horrible if Michigan was
our New York it's like yes I got a bunch
of dates in Grand Rapids this week
everyone's trying to make it into Troy
in Detroit yeah
I hear that Detroit seems a tough one
yeah a bunch of uh
poor like very like unfortunate people
there yeah
yeah that's all neat I mean in New York
and Michigan
do you want to see if
anyone wants to like call into the show
that'd be so fun that'd be great that's
a genius idea I don't know how to do it
okay
reverse
okay so I'll do this and then
with the blood pressure
oh my God I'm not allowed to go live
why I don't know are you Shadow band or
something yeah
let me try Facebook
yeah that'll probably work Facebook
doesn't really care it's ridiculous
I haven't gone live in Forever
you think there's Twitter live oh let's
do Tick Tock live oh Tick Tock Live's
fun
um
no there's no Twitter live right
I don't think so you could do spaces
how do I go live
uh it's like okay they banned me too
yeah there you go
and how do I like accept calls
um what's up guys we're here in Dania
Beach just doing a little pod
call in to the Pod we got Captain right
here everybody and we're just here
answering your questions and giving life
advice I'm 33
uh
scared of the comedy
as Captain right he's 20. what's up
we're gonna
um yeah we should give people life
advice that's a good idea I feel like
we're qualified to do that yeah is give
some life advice yeah we're really good
at life
yeah we made it we're in Dania Beach
we're sitting pretty yeah we can tell
you anything
really
uh do you want to figure out how to
how to call people
yeah I think there's a thing on Tick
Tock where they can join you can you
figure it out yeah guess
and that invite
yeah I think like I said while they come
they can or they can like
well we did do a podcast once before
I remember yeah hosts but we didn't do
any awesome do IG live
I can go live on Instagram and they can
funnel them to me
yeah just go check out Captain Wright's
Instagram yeah
or just message my Instagram and we'll
just call you because I can't go live
because Instagram is thinks I'm gonna
corrupt people with my Communists oh
that's a good idea yeah
that's a better idea
it's so funny I don't even know why they
hate me
no I totally feel that it's so stupid
who wants to talk to us
come talk to us
I don't know how to talk to people in
here
I can have a host host alive with others
share
how do I talk to people on here
so what do you guys think about the uh
ongoing crisis in Turkey
oh yeah they have a crisis going on yeah
yeah like a bunch of people got squished
hey can anyone figure out how to call me
on here
but
God if only I could just do fit uh
yeah
um
does this cancel out my Tick Tock live
so
what do you think about
the uh
turkey situation
I think it's uh crazy that
there was an earthquake it's always at
the perfect time like right when you
forget about the country that something
crazy happens
like and you have to like look at a map
and be like oh that's where that is
yeah it's over there somewhere yeah it's
gonna be like the shittiest thing to
happen as a earthquake
that's so Random
yeah you know they say there's more
earthquakes now because the ice is
melting
so the weight is being shifted around
and it's like Weighing on the tectonic
plates
and also like Mining and Drilling and
stuff oh that makes sense what does
turkey have to mine
I don't know oil that makes sense I
don't know if they have oil
but maybe they didn't mind maybe you
know earthquakes are tough
yeah
at least I didn't get a tsunami
oh yeah they you think today they shot
down like an aircraft
what do you mean they shot down like a
unidentified aircraft over Alaska I
think that's all it says let me look it
up oh I thought you're gonna say the
balloon thing I was like the balloon
thing's old news no it's all the news
but a new one today yeah they got
another thing yeah
aircraft shot down over Alaska
yeah it's really like a cliffhanger it's
like a U.S shoots down high altitude
objects
and that's it
well what do you think it is you think
it's Chinese because you know the
balloon thing so maybe they're just like
hey don't come over here and some like
poor Chinese pilot got murdered yeah he
was just
having fun
maybe he was just kind of [__] with
America a little bit it was just like
stepping over the line
yeah that would be funny as if they just
kept sending over balloons that don't
mean anything just to [__] with us yeah
I guess just a normal ass balloon
foreign
yeah I mean
what if we're just like becoming crazier
and crazier and we're just like an old
man and we're like get off my lawn
yeah or just becoming like more like
schizophrenic
they're like oh that was just a weather
balloon there's no reason to
shoot that down like no or something
we're shooting down like the Bud Light
blimp
yeah we just get addicted to popping
balloons yeah how does this balloon
Defender someone told me I think I read
it somewhere you know there's like only
a couple blimps on Earth
there's only like 15 or something's
crazy like that
yeah we really stopped blimping
yeah it was one accident ruined it for
everyone the Hindenburg yeah which is
like hydrogen there's only 25 blimps in
existence
25. that's so crazy
I know
it's a huge cost to build and run them
you know what Instagram banned me for
what I was like can anyone help me move
I put that on my Instagram oh you're
gonna call and then that they were like
you that's against our laws I was like
what who gives a [__] yeah it's crazy
hello you're live on the air how are you
tonight
good any any words of encouragement
you'd like to share with us
I don't know I just jumped on the stream
and you put your phone number there so I
was gonna call it what do you think
about that as a move you think that that
might be a little crazy
it's a Google number
um it's a Google number
are you talking about Florida
yeah we're in Dania Beach come check it
out we got a show tonight two tomorrow
you're in uh Waco you're in the little
south of Waco yeah okay
oh you're talking about that time I
camped there when I
uh
Owl Creek
well you're the first person that called
we're kind of desperate we don't have
anyone else to talk to so
close to my Instagram we need to make do
with are you like homeless or are you
man I'm in my work van your work fan
cooking dinner down at the river that's
pretty cool do you like the movie Into
The Wild or the book
it's a good well I'm glad your work
doesn't want to spring for a hotel
uh you're just this is your leisure time
yes sir yeah for sure and I'm definitely
in a band though so in a van down by the
river
so uh do you have any questions about
your life that we could give you advice
on
questions about my life
um
uh no man what color should I paint the
van
uh White
that's a good yeah classic yeah it's the
best color you know it's a van color and
you know it's like hey I might be a a
pedophile I might not
well I'm just a carpenter but same thing
no no sounds racist sounds like you're
doing a fake Asian accent
odds and Japanese God's been it's kind
of a little racing van but anyhow
well I'm glad that you're supporting
I'm glad you're supporting Asian rights
we need we need your money
uh
well I'd love to check it out sounds
like a cool van sounds like a very
unique purchase uh and that's how we
express our personalities as through
consumerism
for sure man I'll reveal my identity on
the uh on the YouTube there after we get
done yeah put your phone number on there
okay everyone Instagram him and call him
on IG chat which is the same thing as
your phone number anyways
he's gonna have a private account soon
thanks man
love you bye yeah
see you bud that was chill that was uh
pretty doomsday of him yeah he's just
camping that's what yeah people in Texas
like to do they like to pretend like
they're in the apocalypse yeah which I
guess is like a fun little cute thing
and then go back to your office job
after that yeah that guy just killed a
squirrel with my bare hands I didn't
need to time to type on this computer to
kill somebody yeah I was practicing for
when I do need to
yeah I mean I love the idea of just
relaxing in a van he obviously has his
whole life figured out didn't really
need her help he shouldn't reveal his
identity like he's got warrants which
was pretty funny yeah I mean these
people that aren't famous are only hey
what's up
you're live on the air how is it over in
BC Colombia BC Colombia
yeah eight degrees
[Applause]
right Celsius yeah we use the fahrenheit
we worship at the altar of imperial
units
is that what it's called the imperial
units like the turkey question
um we have to reinforce all the
buildings with like seismic testing
uh to make sure that there's a big
earthquake
everything all apart well I'm glad
you're checking but it really shouldn't
come down to an earthquake in Turkey for
you to do these routine checks yeah
but you know whatever it takes
yeah BC ice
[Music]
they have to all of that
uh theirs or ours
oh someone said this low 30s
yeah we didn't we didn't keep any of
those Native American buildings
yeah yeah
we collapsed them
they're in a little closet yeah they
weren't too hard to take down
yeah you didn't need an earthquake to
take those down
yeah we just use smallpox and white
violence
yeah exactly so I heard you guys uh
murdered a bunch of children in the
churches over there how's that going oh
yeah
and all the uh residential schools
yeah I think it's because like when kids
are away from their loved ones and
they're not loved they just feel sort of
Forgotten and their will to live kind of
um
they basically
took a lot of the children away
um kind of like an orphan giant
orphanage
people didn't really have much of a
choice
but
yeah
I think also smallpox was a thing so
maybe they would have died in their
teepees anyways they just happened to
die at the school
I don't know if they made it that far up
um a few of them died but I don't like I
think that was more like
Southern America
do you think they died of another
disease that the white man gave them
maybe they all got syphilis
there's a problem up here in Canada
so then how did it he's like we did it
with our hands we didn't need a disease
to do it
you're reducing a lot of options here
I'm trying to give you guys an out so
what do you what do you think Gilda
what do you think
what do you think did those kids in
hundreds of thousands of them
[Applause]
to death burial Mountain back from
school I like how you're trying to blame
women for this yeah
foreign
yeah
it's all
they're just following orders
it's all part of their game
yeah it's a fun game
you think about killing kids is like
really do you think it feels like really
good
well yeah I mean I'm sure that uh you
guys did it definitely than we did we
had slaves that was kind of our main
thing yeah at least we gave him jobs
yeah killing kids we're just doing it
for the Love of the Game yeah you're
just having fun at that point
and they would become slave even
problems
well I'm sure that I'm sure that you
guys are bad no one's denying that
so what do you think about your life any
life advice we can give you
[Music]
um
New Life advice yeah what do you need
help with
laser bite
um
don't eat sugar that's good okay that's
good well thanks for giving us life
advice that's good life advice
well I hope you have a good life
yeah you too
awesome you just talked about genocide
flag he called in just to talk about
genocide that was great I kind of
brought it up yeah the way he he was
well versed in that topic yeah he was uh
really
you know we're going over the whole uh
Native American children thing yeah and
I guess they have a lot of that but
yeah I mean I think it's great that
they're like hey we're he was like I'm
just as bad as you are like we did like
America you act like you're so awesome
but yeah you're not that awesome and it
was like he was giving us a secret too
he was like hey by the way hey how are
you tonight you're live on the air
I'm good I'm good hope all's well yeah
we're just chilling
oh I had a funny question that and it's
a hard choice but bear with me just for
the conversation oh funny questions we
were talking about how black people love
to do that
which one would you be oh
what's raisin or a racist a raisin
is the rapist or a racist
um usually they go together
they're more likely to get into heaven
actually know both of those people are
probably
I don't know that's a hard one because
racism doesn't mean you're doing
anything you're just thinking it rape is
like an actual thing that you do yeah so
maybe if it was between a lyncher and a
rapist that's more fair
I would probably be
a rapist because it's easier prey black
people are hard to catch and out wrestle
um
uh it feels better
well that's a whole different can of
worms right there
I mean with rape you're getting
something out of it you're getting to
come but with
being racist and killing a Mexican is
just like that's it's like theoretical
pleasure
yeah you gotta think about it
yeah I guess which one makes you happier
obviously yeah probably Great Captain
what do you want to say
um whatever it makes you happy I guess
between rape and race yeah I mean
to each his own
I'm too lazy for both
so do you have any problems in your life
right now
other than the rape and racism
hmm another one
I just burnt my face in a little as ago
how did what kind of oil like fast food
like french fries
so what do you have what kind of advice
do you have to give to this uh
guy that works in the kitchen
um
what do you have to say to this guy who
can't afford to eat out
uh maybe not have your face like really
close to the pan when you're cooking
food we're trying to see if it was done
hey I might not have money to eat out
them but that EBT that's even better
tonight all these 40 ribeye so oh yeah
if you eat it then we don't have to give
you Health Care yeah that last guy
talked about sugar
so I think it's all correlates
yeah just uh yeah eating good is like
how you stay healthy and if you're like
all like geared up and all like [__]
meet it out then it's like you're gonna
be like a crazy
crazy good worker yeah
all right well thanks for the advice
guys that's good yeah
yeah I feel like we uh really helped
that guy yeah I feel like people don't
really want advice from us no yeah
I feel like they are trying to give
advice to us yeah yeah which is like I
guess he had some good advice
yeah
but it's just funny because like
hopefully it's like a joke like yeah I
don't really want that power how are you
doing how's Los Angeles 818 till I die
what's up
what do you think about the ongoing
crisis in Ukraine
what do you think is the potential
solution oh that's good
you just got to give all the politicians
all the money they want right zielinski
wants like another 600 million so
you just given that I guess would it
would it be nice to fight a war and like
everyone's on your side and giving you
free [__]
we have to earn it yeah that's true we
have to work for it that's true I guess
I feel like we take it with the
regardless yeah that's that's sort of
our whole industry it's like the
military
so well here's a potential solution go
to Israel and Palestine and be like hey
uh they're having some issues maybe lock
them all in a room together be like hey
you know you guys all have issues maybe
you could find the common ground behind
all these issues and yeah approach it
from like an objective maybe put put
them on an escape room so they have to
get through it can we start with that
food I think none of those places have
good food so that's off the table
yeah
yeah Natural Gas
[Music]
I think that
um really it's the US's fault that this
whole thing happened because we were not
really nice to Russia and we started the
Cold War and like [__] with them for
like 100 years
that came out yeah they're apparently
America did it
revealed Abu Gray
which America also denied
yeah I mean it's kind of funny because
we all stopped talking about it it
happened and everyone stopped talking
about it so I guess it was us like
if it was anyone else we'd be so pissed
yeah
people who someone said America is like
the world's biggest terrorist
yeah but we are like the official voice
of society and modernity yeah a moderna
and whatnot one question for you guys
I've always wanted to ask you guys are
both stand-up comics yeah
that's pretty cool like I've always
wondered like I'm one of those guys
and like
how do you know when your actual um
[Music]
like going on stage with people who are
expected to laugh
um I don't I don't think I've ever like
had that
moment where I'm like yeah I got it yeah
I think like funny is like such a vague
notion and to be like Oh I'm funny or
I'm not funny it's like yeah you could
be funny at any moment at any time it's
like happy like I'm happy yeah are you
happy like 51 of the time yeah
I had to go on stage and make like a
little people laugh
well that's just the muscle you build
I've been I had a lot of confidence when
I first started I was like I'm gonna
make them laugh now I'm like what kind
of laugh is it are they laughing at are
they laughing yeah
are they laughing like
you know sometimes it's like a
you get off and you do good and you're
like yeah I'm funny and you get off and
you do bad and you're like I'm not funny
at all
so it changes it's like a roller coaster
can you be funny right now
yeah
it's like I
had the last school is expecting a lot
like that I'm
scared so you gotta sneak up on them we
don't have the where do you work what do
you do to make people laugh at work
uh this sounds weird but I'm actually a
doctor oh so you're like this guy's
bleeding everywhere and people laugh a
bunches
wow this guy really we're losing this
patient and everyone's dying
yeah how do you have the confidence to
stick your hand into someone's ass
squeeze their anal glands
dude honestly so that's why I could
never be a urologist Urology is a
specialty that is apparently very
competitive but all you do all day is
look at people's penises do you have to
stick your finger in them
you have to do like prostate exams but
every patient that you see like in
clinic just shows you their penis so you
see like 30 people's penis every day in
clinic
and it's considered like a desirable
specialty
I think it's uh
it's a good way to spend your day
yeah
what if you just start looking at Dicks
all day and you just start wondering
what they taste like yeah
and then it tastes different based on
how they look like you're the first
blind urologist that has to use their
mouth
okay
like since it smells good
yeah I mean there's a lot of factors
that go into dick taste there's sweat
sweat it's a good one the skin type
the color
yeah yeah temperature is big
um
[Music]
your diet you guys want to hear one girl
story from that's good yes
[Music]
Family Medicine Clinic and we had us
working with an STD clinic by like a
college town it was like an art clinic
so there were a lot of young women
coming in the past few days
hell yeah
and she's having like vaginal itching so
yeah
microscope and you you look for like the
kind of infection women always have
vagina issues so it's kind of gross I do
yeah and so she you know we did the same
thing you know we found the fungi we
came back to the clinic and I'm about to
give her the prescription for the
antifungal
and she says uh is it okay if I don't
take this you know is it safe I don't
take it so I asked her you know why
don't you want to take this medication
and she said uh my boyfriend likes the
taste of it
of the fungus
yeah or [__] fungus wait did you say
the test came back positive for fungus
yeah a yeast infection
oh she likes that he likes the yeast
yeah he likes the taste of it so she was
wondering if she didn't want to take the
anti from the road
yeah in sand yeah it's an acquired taste
just be like hey you're gonna have to
adjust it's going to taste a little
different but also it's like you don't
want to get too used to that because you
start going down that rabbit hole Yeah
and then you just start like I mean it's
so crazy if she eats it and then she
becomes like self like
nutrient like she can just like not buy
food anymore and just eat that forever
she's like a worm
it's like a circle
that sounds a bad thing I guess you know
well thank you for the story I hope that
uh you have anything uh going on in your
life we could give you advice on
what relationship do you advice do you
have for this guy that hates dicks
um like how do you keep a long
relationship
spicy spicy
you uh
you fulfill her needs
yeah that's it yeah just try to
be uh you know open to eating her fungus
yeah if she wants her fungus eaten
eat it
yeah that's that's like a quadrillion
way if you're having sex with like
fungus and your girlfriend yeah it's
like you're having sex from the uh The
Last of Us people wasn't that a fungus
yeah well my advice for your
relationship to keep a long relationship
going as a doctor that hates dicks
is that
um I would just you know
grab her ass every day
oh yeah or your favorite body part just
grab it like out of nowhere just like
disrespectfully
I like that let her know she's a piece
of me
um
well you're a piece of me too so if
she's not like touching you and like
trying to like you know
you know like do like things that you
would do to the opposite sex with you
it's like she probably isn't going to be
with you long if you're just like an
intellectual security guard
that's true
that's true I like that thanks for the
advice yeah I hope she hopefully you get
your life together you dumb doctor
yeah please do we need it where is it
la oh
beautiful
all right see you man
all right take care
let's get another that guy was fun
yeah he's a good doctor hopefully
from Philadelphia La doctor ooh
Philadelphia this guy's gonna be angry
hello hey how angry are you on a scale
of one to ten
uh plus seven
call it an angry Philadelphia and the
Eagles are in the Super Bowl and you're
still mad are you gonna Riot when it
happens
well yeah I mean that kind of just comes
with the territory
yeah that's good
so what's going on with you fellas so
why are white people okay with rioting
for the Super Bowl but they're not okay
with rioting for police violence
uh I could argue with them about that
all the time I kind of always wonder uh
every time a sports team does well we
can go crazy but
everything else but kind of you know
they got a problem with it yeah like why
wouldn't we Riot if there's so much
wealth inequality and everyone's a
[__] Uber driver
yeah I don't know man I don't know what
to tell you
what people love their Sports more than
life I kind of I kind of resonate with
those people because seeing someone
score a touchdown makes me want to climb
a Street Post
yeah I can take my shirt off like he
might be good at that but I'm good at
this yeah I'm kind of comparing uh
talents it's like amongst other I mean
people I think
women
you know the usual
I think you went in between one of your
many skyscrapers in Philadelphia because
you cut out for a minute
oh I'm sorry you know what I had
headphones let me take them off
I'm sure that the way the flexi of
headphones
hey I'm sure that it's not the
headphones but maybe it is
sorry that is not the headphone
uh so what do you think any anything
you're going through in life we could
give you advice on
uh yeah you know what I do
um you've been doing comedy for what
good amount of time before you uh grown
kill Tony's book and all that right yeah
so what were you doing before that
I was just living with my mom
oh is your food done
are you backing up right now
yeah there's something beeping is there
are you about to Flatline
that's a crazy boy
yeah I got an old ass card
well I would just say that you just need
to
do comedy for eight years
and before that you know maybe just live
with your mom and then live in a van so
you don't have to have a job and you can
do comedy all day
you know actually doing stand up
yourself like as far as like just
watching them and just was it something
you were always into that or just
randomly coming in your life
uh comedy was something that was in my
life through the Joe Rogan podcast and
then I made a conscious effort to start
it and approach it like a job and
approach it like a craft like practicing
violin you know if you practice violin
for three years people are going to be
like wow you need to spot a Carnegie
Hall so it's like it's crazy to me to
see these comedians that are just like
I'm just like a great person and I just
need to step on stage and in six months
I should have an HBO special
oh yeah no definitely not you got to put
in the the groundwork for anything else
you know but uh yeah well
you say how how does she do a lot of
people seeing you won't kill Tony and uh
it's been cool to follow you I guess
your YouTube channel and all that you've
been doing this on the van to just
seeing you torn all over the country now
I mean it's just pretty cool to see the
early stages of thanks man hopefully
I don't [__] it up
but the supportive crowd you've got
going and you definitely keep killing it
yeah
I what was his what was his name he's a
comedian too Captain right
thank you
all right so yeah
I feel like the Liberty Bell that's
advice yeah that guy was very positive
that was like the exact opposite of the
uh genocide guy
yeah the Canadian guy was sort of like
yeah he was just like yeah hundreds of
thousands of children were murdered
right next to where I live and it wasn't
a disease which is very like practical
about it right yeah just what happened
and I'm not gonna like try to feel a
different way and change the facts yeah
I feel like he's the tour guide at the
museum that Indian genocide Museum
yeah he just was really excited about it
yeah
it's like if you're not trying to avoid
negative emotions then what are you
trying to do yeah which is fine I had
like a bit about that for a while it's
like I went to the 911 museum and I
thought about like who's applying to
work here
like what is the interview like at the
911 museum they're like what inspires
you about 911 to work here
whoever are you on 9 11. yeah unless
someone who's like really excited like
oh my God
it's like a funny joke if you go on
stage and you're like
I don't think it should ever ask someone
during a job interview where they were
during 9 11 unless you're hiring for the
911 museum that's yeah that's funny it's
like a beginning of a joke yeah to be
something else there you have to find
some fundamental truth about 9 11
museums and how it's different from
other museums yeah
a 911 museum is like a museum
but for
if you can't uh
on a very small moment of History
imagine if they did Night at the Museum
at night at the 911 museum do you think
there's like an Iraq war wing of the 911
museum there is there actually is yeah
what do they say about it they just show
you that like uh everyone who all the
hijackers were just kind of like uh they
try to make a case for the Iraq War they
control it and they're like they're like
yeah you know they thought they were
doing it for religion but they're just
tricked into flying planes into Towers
and then it started the floor and I was
like all right they were tricked
well how do you know they were tricked
maybe they yeah maybe they wanted they
thought this was the best idea maybe it
was the best idea well it's pretty crazy
they came we were reading and we kind of
got freaked out because they came in I'm
from Orlando and it says they came into
America at the Orlando Airport and they
learned how to fly around here south
Florida yeah I know you guys are way too
much yeah because we gave them we we let
them do that in the intellectual backing
no Florida yeah they're trying to get
their license they're like hey why do
you want to find they're like oh no
reason at all I just want to do that fun
yeah that's the thing before 9 11. well
I guess there were still terrorists and
hijackers yeah but they should have been
aware because they made it popular yeah
the Israeli team got murdered yeah
um but yeah the hijackers and 9 11. I
just think it's funny that like 9 11 is
like
like there was no reason to attack Iraq
yeah that makes sense we should have
just went and killed that one guy and
that should have been at Pakistan but
then we completely just well yeah you
know the whole country gets it yeah like
go through the whole museum and at the
end they're like and then we attacked
Iraq yeah it's basically it's at the end
and it kind of it shows you like why
do they have like an Afghanistan part
yeah kind of and then it shows you there
was another attack on the World Trade
Centers before that was like
unsuccessful
yes
so imagine the guy being like yeah that
was crazy yeah for some reason people
really hate the World Trade Centers yeah
because they're built diagonally it's
probably like people with OCD
yeah
they're trying to
they were trying to create a World Trade
Center one the whole time yeah
it's crazy how many skyscrapers we built
and how many of them are still standing
that is crazy the Twin Towers are like
one of the only ones that have fell yeah
it's like we're really good at making
skyscrapers
sometimes oh my God the show starts in
30 minutes
should we get out of here yeah I guess
all right see you guys I feel like we
got life advice